almost 30 years ago my country was
facing the need to rebuild everything
from scratch after years of sciatica
patient Estonia regained its
independence but we were left with
nothing no infrastructure no
administration no legal code an
organizational chaos out of necessity
the state leaders back then had to make
some daring choices the ones that a
country could afford there was a lot of
experimentation and uncertainty but also
bit of luck involved particularly in the
fact that we could count in a number of
brilliant visionaries cryptographers and
engineers I was just a kid back then
today we're called the most digital
society on earth I'm from Estonia and
we've been declaring taxes online since
2001 we've been using digital identity
and signature since 2002 we've been
voting online since 2005 and for today
pretty much the whole range of the
public services that you can imagine
education police justice starting a
company applying for benefits looking at
your health record or challenging a
parking ticket
it's everything that is done online in
fact it's much easier to tell you what
are the free things we cannot yet do
online we have to show up to pick up our
ID documents get married or divorced or
sell real estate that's pretty much it
so that's why don't freak out when I'll
tell you that
every year I can wait to start doing my
tax declaration because all I have to do
is sit in my couch with a mobile phone
swipe a few pages with prefilled data on
income and deductions and hit submit
after three minutes and looking at the
tax return amount with
actually feels like a quiet rewarding
experience no tax advisers know
collecting receipts no doing the math
and have I mentioned that I have not
visited a state office for almost seven
years indeed one of the features of the
modern life that has no reason to exist
anymore considering technological
possibilities of today is the labyrinth
of bureaucracy we've almost got rid of
it completely in Estonia in an effort
coordinated by the government that has
also digitized itself for instance
Cabinet of Ministers work in a cabinet
is absolutely paperless the central idea
behind this development is
transformation of the state role and
digitalization of trust think about it
in most countries people don't trust
their governments and the governments
don't trust them back and all the
complicated paper-based formal
procedures are supposed to solve that
problem except that they don't they just
make life more complicated
I believe Estonian experience is showing
that technology can be the remedy for
getting the trust back while creating an
efficient user-centric as service
delivery system that actively responds
to citizens needs we did not do it by
digitizing bureaucracy as it is but by
rather agreeing in a few strong common
principles redesigning rules and
procedures getting rid of unnecessary
data collection and tasked application
and becoming open and transparent let me
give you a glimpse into some of the key
I Estonia design principles today first
it is essential to guarantee privacy and
confidentiality of data and information
this is achieved for a strong digital
identity that is issued by the state and
compatible with everything in fact every
Estonian has one their identity
is doubled with a strong digital
signature that is accepted used and
legally binding both in Estonia and
European Union when the system can
properly and securely identify who is
using it after logging in it will
provide access to the personal data of
the citizen and all public services
within one tool and allow to authorize
anything by saying digitally a second
principle and one of the most
transformative is called once only it
means that the state cannot ask for the
same data
more than once nor can store it in more
than one place for instance if you've
already provided your birth or marital
certificate so the population registry
this is the only place where this data
is going to be held and no other
institution will be ever asking for it
again once only is a very powerful rule
as it defines the whole structure of the
data collection in a country what
information is collected and who is
responsible for maintaining it making
sure we avoid centralization of data
duplication of data and guarantee that's
actually up-to-date this distributed
approach also avoids the problem of the
single point of failure but since the
data cannot be replicated or collected
more than once
it means that the design has to keep in
mind secure and robust access to that
information at all times so the public
institution can offer a service this is
exactly the role of the data exchange
platform called the X road that has been
in use since 2001 just like a highway
it connects public sector databases and
registries local municipalities and
businesses organizing a real-time secure
and regulated data exchange setting an
auditable trace after
move here's a screenshot of a live feed
showing all the requests performed on X
road and all the services that it
actually facilitates and this is the
real picture of all the connections
between public and private sector
databases as you can see there is no
central database whatsoever
confidentiality and privacy are
definitely very important but in a
digital world reliability and integrity
of information is just critical for
operations for instance if someone
changes your medical health record let's
say allergies without you or your doctor
knowing treatment could be deadly that's
why in a digital society a system like
Estonian one when there's almost no
paper originals there's almost only
digital originals integrity of data data
exchange rules software components and
log files is paramount we use a form of
block chain that we invented back in
2007 way before blockchain even became a
thing to check and guarantee the
integrity of data in real time
blockchain is our auditor and a promise
but no access to the data or data
manipulation remains unrecorded data
ownership is another key principle in
the design of the system aren't you
worried by the fact that the
government's tech companies and other
businesses around the world claim data
they collected about you there's
generally refused to give access to that
information and often failed to prove
how it was used or shared with third
parties I don't know for me it seems
like a quiet disturbing situation the
Estonian system is based on the
principle that an individual is the
owner of the data collected about him
thus has an absolute right to know what
information is collected and who has
been accessing it every time a policeman
a doctor or any state officer is
accessing a personal information of the
citizens online first they only get
success it after logging in to the
information they're authorized to see to
do their job and secondly every time
they're making requests this is saved in
a log file these detailed log file is
part of the state public services and
allows real transparency making sure no
privacy violation will remain unnoticed
to the citizen now of course this is
only a simplified summary of all the
design principles that es tony is built
on and now government is building up to
get ready for use of artificial
intelligence and building a whole new
generation of public services proactive
services that would activate seamlessly
based on different life situations that
people might be in such as child birth
unemployment or starting a business now
of course running a digital society with
no paper backup can be an issue even
though we trust our systems to be solid
but one can never be too cautious as we
experienced back in 2007 when the first
cyber incident happened and it literally
blocked part of our networks making
access to the services impossible for
ours we survived but this event puts
cyber security at the very top of agenda
both in terms of strengthening the
platform and backing it up so how do you
backup a countrywide system in a small
state where everything is super close
well for instance you can export copy of
the data outside the country territory
to an extra territorial space of an
embassy so today we have those data
embassies that are holding of the most
critical digital assets of Estonia
guaranteeing continuity of operations
protection of our data and most
importantly our sovereignty even in case
of a physical attack on our territory
some of you might be thinking by now
where are the downsides well going all
digital is administrative Lee and let's
be honest financially more efficient
interfacing primarily with computer
systems might create an impression that
the human factor elected politicians and
participating in democratic processes is
somehow less important and there are
also some people who feel threatened by
pervasive technology that might make
their skills obsolete so all in all
unfortunately
running a country and the digital
platform has not saved us
from political power struggles and
polarization in the society as we have
seen in the last elections well until
there are humans involved one last
question if everything is location
independent and I can access all of the
services from anywhere in the world why
cannot others tap into some of these
services even if they don't reside
within Estonian borders five years ago
we launched a governmental startup
called a residency program that for
today joins tens of thousands of people
these are business men and women from a
hundred and thirty six different
countries who established their
businesses digitally who do their
banking online and who run their
companies virtually over Estonia
platform within European Union legal
framework using an e identity card
similar to mine and all of that from
anywhere in the world
the Estonian system is location
independent and user centric it
prioritizes inclusiveness openness and
reliability
it puts security and transparency at its
center and the data into the hands of
the rightful owner the person they refer
to don't take my word for it try it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]